welcome to prototype to production where
we go from notebook code to a deployed
model in the cloud i'm nikita and i'm
going to show you all the foundational
concepts you'll need in order to build
train scale and deploy machine learning
models on google cloud we'll cover the
basics and also dive into more advanced
topics like hyper parameter tuning
distributed training and experiment
tracking
we'll use an image classification model
as our main example for this entire
series but many of the concepts covered
are still very applicable to other data
and model types in this episode we'll
start by talking about the benefits of
running machine learning in a cloud
environment
then we'll look at how to use notebooks
on google cloud
[Music]
if you're anything like me your machine
learning journey probably starts in a
notebook
maybe you're running jupiter in a local
environment or maybe you're using collab
or a kaggle kernel
but while experimentation in notebooks
is great it's easy to hit a wall when it
comes time to scale those experiments
suddenly your concerns are far more than
just getting the highest accuracy score
what if you have a long-running job want
to do distributed training host a model
for online predictions
or maybe your use case requires more
granular permissions around security and
data privacy
what's your data going to look like at
serving time and how will you monitor
the performance of your model over time
for all of that we turn to the cloud
let's jump in and see how all of this
works step one is to set up our
environment we'll use vertex ai which is
google cloud's manage machine learning
platform
from the vertex ai section of the cloud
console select workbench
vertex ai workbench is the place to go
in google cloud if you want to work in a
notebook so if you're already using
notebooks this environment will feel
familiar
under manage notebooks select new
notebook give the notebook a name and
under permissions we'll run our notebook
as a service account
then under advanced settings you can
customize your notebook by providing
your own docker image
changing the hardware profile and adding
gpus
workbench notebooks also shut down
automatically after a period of
inactivity so you won't incur additional
charges when you aren't using the
instance
to enable terminal access just select
this box at the bottom
and once our notebook is ready we'll see
this open jupyter lab button turn blue
the launcher shows the different options
you have when creating notebooks
workbench provides multi-kernel support
so you can create notebooks for
tensorflow r pytorch a custom
environment etc all within the same
instance
and when i say kernel i just mean the
managed environment where your notebook
runs they come pre-installed with common
data science libraries but you can also
pip install additional libraries that
aren't included by default
if i click on the tensorflow 2 kernel
this will open up a notebook that comes
pre-installed with tensorflow as well as
other libraries that are useful for data
science
workbench managed notebooks also come
with git integration so you can make use
of version control and even sync your
notebook's git repo with the remote
github url
you can change the hardware profile of
your instance and add gpus so this means
you can test your code on a smaller and
cheaper machine and then modify the
hardware when you want to run a longer
experiment or boost the training
performance
this sets up our deep learning
environment where we can explore data
train models and interact with other
google cloud services
but more on all of that later in this
episode we took the first step in
getting from prototyping machine
learning in a local environment to
production machine learning in the cloud
we learned about vertex ai workbench
which is the place to go in google cloud
if you want to use a notebook if you're
interested in running your own workbench
notebooks or testing this out for
yourself click on the tutorials linked
in the description in the next episode
we'll learn about storing data in google
cloud for machine learning
don't forget to like subscribe for more
great content and i'll see you next time